en el último vídeo quería yo dibujar una
molécula que en realidad tenía por
nombre o al menos yo le puse por nombre
el 2002 propio esta no y en ocasiones
estos nombres los escriben juntos a
veces separados pero bueno el punto es
que lo hicimos bien en el vídeo anterior
pero no debería llamarse así nunca de
los nuncas veremos una molécula llamarse
de esta forma y ahí les va por qué por
qué digo yo que eso nunca lo van a ver
en alguna molécula y como nos decían
aquí tenemos un eta no en realidad nos
dice que nuestra cadena sería de 7
carbonos verdad entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 moléculas de carbono y nos dicen
que en el segundo carbono digamos
tenemos aquí el 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 en el
segundo vamos a tener un grupo propio el
propio y tiene 3 carbonos verdad
entonces tenemos 1
3 verdad y simplemente lo enlazamos a
este segundo carbono entonces lo que me
hicieron notar en un usuario de aquí de
khan academy es que esta molécula en
realidad si partimos de la molécula no
debería llamarse dos propios eta no y
eso es simplemente porque deberíamos
considerar la cadena más larga verdad la
cadena más larga en este caso si por
ejemplo empezamos aquí tendremos
123456789 carbonos en esta en esta otra
cadena lo cual nos da una cadena mucho
más larga bueno más larga por dos
carbonos al menos que el caso que
habíamos pintado entonces en realidad
esto debería dibujarse de la siguiente
forma nos consideramos la cadena más
larga verdad nos consideramos la cadena
más larga y ésta dijimos tiene nueve
carbonos entonces este es un no nano
porque son
y puros enlaces sencillos entonces si
enumeramos podemos poner 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 y 9 y fíjense que lo enumeramos en
esa dirección porque aquí tenemos un
grupo metilo verdad tenemos un grupo
metilo que para poder enumerar debe
estar debe obtener la menor
digamos posición posible de lo contrario
estaría en el 1 2 3 4 5 6 y en este caso
está en la posición número 4 entonces
tenemos un grupo metilo entonces este se
llamará metil y vamos a ponerle un 4
porque se encuentra en el carbono 4
entonces este es el 4 metil no nano
entonces esto me lo hicieron notar me lo
hizo anotar a alguien de ustedes de la
canaca de mí y en realidad es que este
nombre me lo inventé verdad por eso es
que a lo mejor no salió correcto como no
en realidad nunca van a ver escrita esta
molécula si alguien por ejemplo la
etiqueta en un laboratorio sería
justamente de esta forma sería el cuatro
metil no nano verdad justamente por
considerar la cadena más larga entonces
espero que no haya causado una confusión
mayor pero
si quería dejar claro que este ejemplo
en realidad era un mal ejemplo y que en
realidad esta molécula se llama 4 metil
no nano